As the
ransom of these actors rises like this
, now the price of clothes is getting higher and now it is getting more expensive, but the price of clothes is getting higher,
but the quality of people keeps changing to poor quality
.
This is Park Hye-soo
, who played the role of Berlin in the Common Economic Zone
. Nice to meet you.
Hello My name is
Tae-I
, Beaupai a Professional
.  I'm Lee Hyun-woo, who plays the role of Rio
. You can start right away. Yes
[Music]
What? You have a plan for me, it's a
big one, but
I really want you
to do it.
The fact that it was picked up for the second
time seems very symbolic in itself.
Actually, caper-
style movies and
dramas are very familiar to us. It's something we
've seen and enjoyed a lot
, but I felt the heat when I saw it in that Spanish drama.
It was freedom. There are many people
who can execute the professor.
Well, Denver is also powerful and
there must be many people. Why did you bother
to
pick up a woman called Tokyo first?
That's why I think
Kang Joo who stole raw money gets
chased to death or ends up in prison, but a
robber who stole a huge amount of
money changes the world and
becomes a hero
. The most important thing in this house of paper
was that freedom.  Freedom
So, this servant's house
can be called b-level masturbation.
I think
[Music]
before we start classes in earnest.
From now on, we
will communicate in my unspeakable native language. I
will use nicknames instead of names for addressing. Aside from names
quickly,
it will be
safe not to know your identity in case of illness.
Now
, how about the name of the city?
I like where I want to be, and I like places where I like the
pronunciation better, so
pick one as you like
and shoot them all at once
.
It was a very awkward situation because Rio joined a little late
,
but he introduces himself as Rio and now names himself
Rio.
I did it, so thanks to that, the
scene became a little bit harmful. I just
clapped and
really, the crew here, the actors here, the crew,
what the production team,
it was really close to 2 million, so 200 people
knew what a performance
was.  Years ago, I acted as a senior's child,
so I
met seniors a long time ago.  There are a lot of
them. Anyway,
Hyunwoo really received a
lot of love from the staff around him, especially the female staff.
That
's why he
was
really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really pretty, to the point where all
the really good-looking actresses envy
him.
I thought I would become a Hallyu actor, but
when I saw the production presentation the other day, I saw that he
really had all the elements of a Hallyu actor
.
Really the
greatest
popularity on earth,
so it's really cool
. It's because of the grades, it's because of the grades
.
[Music]
Everyone's attention, from now on,
North Koreans will move to the right, South Koreans to the
left, with me as the center
.  This is now that Spanish professor
was just Freedom, but since this is now
talking about the unification of North and South Korea, this includes
social socialism and something a little different from Kim Il-sungism
.
So many actors must have thought
that way, but I personally
Just for now, what we've seen is
happening in Spain, and our
script is happening in the situation of Korea
, and the situation and things are
just standard culture.
I think I was able to create a character like Denver in Korea, Berlin in Korea, so I did that, but when I
acted together,
emotionally, I felt that everyone else was
doing their own
character like that,
Liu, Korea, Professor in Korea.
[Music] Execution of
this woman
.
[Music]
Being able to perfectly control humans is
fear  It
's a sense of immersion and suction that comes from the concentration of the person who has a great suction power as a person.
He
has really great acting skills in that area,
so I watched it a lot on set.
There were moments like that with each other from behind.
When the hostages are all done with hyung's acting,
they just take it all,
so those moments are not a cure-all, the
other actors and seniors are all a
bit
like that, and the acting ability that turns even the actors on the set into audiences is
very terrifying and charismatic,
but then  In fact, I was very grateful as
an actor who could act that there were actors who could be accepted like that
. It was the same with all of us robbers,
but the hostages there were
also actors who were very trained on stage.
Rather than thinking that we will all follow it, it's
not even the ability to
overcome it, and I've been talking a lot with the writer and the director about the tendency of Berlin in the Korean version
.  It
could be another attraction, so in fact,
since they accepted all the
acting, it seems like they made the other people feel comfortable acting, and they were
great actors, and
[Music]
It wasn't enough that it was very dangerous,
so now my colleagues even monitor each
other.
It's not something a person who came to religion would
say to my colleagues. When I approach
the treehouse with the same goal as the difference in values ​​between Berlin and Tokyo,
I
have a direction to go regardless of means and methods, and while doing some
damage, I am afraid
or hostage.  take control  But
the concept of Tokyo is now conflicting, and
I'm fighting over values.
Even the taboo that says no to good has
been broken, and if we leave it as it
is, the professor's plan will eventually become a sin.
It was included in the script,
so I
don't think there was a big problem with fighting or clashing
with each other, and there's that liveliness that the actor Jeon Jong-seo himself has
.
It was
fun after doing
it because there was that.
In
fact, that kind of
serious
tension is created
just by preparing their own performances and rehearsing
.  The
actors on set had a lot of people who maintained and maintained the mood in the scene. We
are personally close to each other
, but if there is
a conflict between Berlin and Denver,
it is not like that day when the camera is running or
not
, maintaining that tension a little
.  It was almost just a
unity here Unity was so fun,
so fun, all of them were filmed
Professor, why pretend
to be an individual at that time?
The memory of working hard in Ingeuk
The memory of digesting 40 scenes and 60 scenes in a day is
like that.  It can
be quite difficult to breathe with these people because
if you don't shoot everything like this, even if you
shoot for a year,
you can see it once a month, well, once every two months, once every three
months.
We did some rehearsals,
so we tried to make a little
bit of
a breath that we can understand just by looking at each other like this, just by looking into each other's eyes
.
We lived together in a space in Gyeonggi-do for about six months. We
spent
one to two or three seasons with the actors every few months on the set
where we had to rob the Mint, and many of the photos on my cell phone
were sitting in Cho Tae-guk.
There are so many scenes of these actors sitting in the first row waiting like this, looking at the script and talking to each other. It is
very memorable to me,
and being in the
same space with such great actors for such a long
time itself is like a dream to me, this place
I think I am very grateful to myself, so
please give me the ensemble award
[
Laughs] I hope people can feel that everyone did their best to create a new joint economic zone for the House of Paper, not the Korean version.